madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct pour le dernier de nos débats
organisé à l'occasion de l'élection
départementale de la semaine prochaine
dernier débat consacré à la à la
sonéloire en partenariat avec le journal
de sonnéloire et avec vous benoî
montonny bonjour bonjour La sonnéloire
qui a basculé à à gauche en 2004 depuis
elle est présidée par des socialistes il
y a eu d'abord Christophe CUG ensuite
Arnaud mondebourg et puis Rémy chintron
Rémy chintron qui fait partie de nos
invités bonjour remémy chintron bonjour
vous présidez le département depuis 2012
c'est-à-dire depuis que ARN mondbourg
est entrer dans le gouvernement héros
André Akari bonjour bonjour vous
représentez ici l'UMP ses alliés de
l'uasl l'Union pour l'avenir de la
sonéloire François loto bonjour vous
êtes le secrétaire régional d'Europe
Écologie les vertes et sébastienoin
bonjour secrétaire départemental du
Front national je précise que vous êtes
tous les quatre candidats mais chacun
dans un canton différents puisqu'il
s'agit ici d'un débat consacré à
l'ensemble du département et non pas un
canton en particulier si vous à la
maison vous voulez poser une question
réagir et bien vous le pouvez via notre
site internet
bourgogne.france3.fr via Twitter hlvel
Bourgogne F3 Bourgogne et puis bien sûr
sur notre page Facebook un petit regard
général peut-être sur sur la sonnéloire
sur le bilan de la mandature qui vient
de de s'écouler reméy Chatron vous avez
donc pris la présidence en cours de
mandature comment vous jugez votre bilan
est-ce que d'abord c'est le vôtre ou
est-ce que c'est celui de d'arna
montebour c'est le bilan de la majorité
le bilan de la majorité départementale
deux mots pour qualifier ce bilan je
pense bah celui les engagements tenus
simplement les engagements tenus en
matière de gestion financière 5 ans sans
fiscalité 5 ans de désendettement 5 ans
de maintien de nos investissements un
département protecteur nous avons
amplifié nos politiques en direction des
personnes âgées sur la dépendance sur
les maisons de retraite publiqu
accessibles à tous pour les collèges
également pour tout un tas de sur les
compétences qui sont qui sont les nôtres
au quotidien puis enfin une dernière
thématique que nous avons beaucoup
développé c'est l'attractivité faire en
sorte que ce département attire attire
des nouvelles populations attire aussi
des entreprises et c'est le travail que
nous faisons quand nous aménageons le
territoire quand nous luttons contre la
désertification médicale quand nous
mettons en place le Très Haut Débit
numérique quand voilà quand nous faisons
des aménagements sur l'ensemble du
territoire alors vous Andr carry depuis
plusieurs années vous êtes à la tête de
l'opposition tout à fait on peut
imaginer que ce bilan de Rémy chintron
et des présidents précédents n'est
évidemment pas le vôtre ne vous
satisfait pas écoutez tout d'abord cette
élection départementale est essentielle
mais à plusieurs titres euh elle est
essentielle parce que elle va permettre
aussi à l'ensemble des citoyens
d'envoyer un signe fort à ce
gouvernement socialiste de cette
majorité socialiste qui a depuis
plusieurs années procédé à un véritable
matraquage financier financier aussi
asphixier les territoires notamment les
communes et puis aussi c'est un échec
sur le front de l'emploi
essentiel aussi pour le département
parce que c'est effectivement cette
élection départementale elle est au au
cœur de la vie quotidienne euh plusieurs
la mobilisation doit être importante
puisque on est face à une politique de
proximité tel que les territoires ruraux
tels que les collèges donc il faut
effectivement mobiliser la population et
c'est pas facile puisque le gouvernement
a quand même expliqué pendant plusieurs
mois que les départements allaient
disparaître donc je pense que c'est un
moment important pour montrer au signe
un signe fort de changer cette majorité
socialistes cette majorité
départementale où on a pu s'apercevoir
que 11 années 11 années de gestion trop
d'habitants et trop de territoires ont
été oubliés le président parle de 5 ans
non c'est 11 années de gestion
socialiste voilà c'est notre pour
l'instant notre constat on y reviendra
en détail en détaillant bien sûr tous
les thèmes que vous avez abordé l'un et
l'autre François loto vous alors vous
n'avez aucun élu hein au conseil général
en pour l'instant dans le futur conseil
départemental on le verra euh comment
vous considérezvous l'action de vos
est-ce qu'il faut dire vos amis
socialistes ah oui oui mais nous avons
peu d'ennemis mais des amis de
préférence ce bilan effectivement est
celui d'une assemblée départementale
dans laquelle les écologistes n'étaient
pas représentés par
conséquent on ne peut l'aborder que
comme chaque citoyen peut le faire
c'est-à-dire en observant les effets de
la politique de la majorité
sortante nous observons que ce conseil
général a publié ce qu'il a publié et
les commentaires dans la presse je suis
désolé mais monsieur Akari mais un bon
point indiscutable devrait réjouir
l'opposition qui là-dessus fait preuve
de mauvaise foi la gestion a été bonne
les échos mettaient récemment en avant
la soné Loire en a donnant un exemple
pour sa bonne gestion on en reparlera
mais il est dommage que ça ne se soit
pas accompagné d'une orientation sur des
choix suffisamment clairs il y a deux
défauts qui ressortent de ce bilan un
certain déficit démocratique et un
manque de cohérence c'est des mots sans
doute un peu durs mais qui soulignent en
fait notre déception de bonnes choses
ont été engagées de très bonnes choses
mais qui n'aboutissent pas suffisamment
informer mieux recueillir les avis des
citoyens ça a été fait mais sans les
associer vraiment au projet alors que la
demande de coopération citoyenne est
forte gérer les déchets mettre en œuvre
un agenda 21 un Plan climat énergie
territoriale c'est bien et ça reste au
milieu du gay c'est mieux que de vouloir
tout le contraire mais ça reste décevant
donc si on est un peu scolaire on
pourrait dire que peut mieux faire
et puis comment comprendre que que on
gâche les moyens dégagés par une gestion
rigoureuse dans une aventure assez
scabreuse comme C parc ou qu'on réduise
l'aide à l'écotourisme par exemple mais
je pense que nous allons en reparler
tout à fait on va en reparler mais on va
parler avec le le Front national
Sébastien loin vous le vous n'avez aucun
élu au Conseil Général de saéloir a
priori on peut dire que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup d'amis politiques non plus qui
siègent qu'est-ce que veut faire le le
Front national dans ce conseil
départemental on sait que ça a jamais
été des élections très faciles pour le
FM oui tout à fait ce n'est pas des
élections faciles pour nous euh malgré
tout quand nous battons le terrain
actuellement pour ces élection
départemental nous constatons donc que
grand nombre quand même des habitants de
sonellloir donc sont dans une détresse
dans une misère humaine et avec une
injustice sociale nous pouvons aussi
constater donc une dette he quand même
qui est qui est énorme donc 3 ans 319
millions d'euros hein quand même donc
certes monsieur chintron a fait des
efforts hein pour pour diminuer la dette
mais euh c'est trop tard on a laissé
quand même accroître la dette quand même
pendant plusieurs années que ça soit
sous le régime de la droite sous la
présidence de Monsieur cirug et après
par Monsieur Montebourg donc voilà la la
dette quand même quelque chose de
primordial qu' va falloir absolument
réviser et la faire baisser le plus
rapidement possible et pour ça voilà il
va falloir aussi être beaucoup plus à
l'écoute donc des sonnéloiriens car ils
sont dans une détresse mais énorme
actuellement donc certes nous sommes sur
des élections départementales mais nous
voyons bien que la politique nationale
qui étaé menée par le gouvernement
Hollande et Vals et auparavant héros
amène à une France vraiment mais
catastrophique dans une grande misère
très profonde et suite à ça nous pouvons
bah que sortir voilà je vais je vais
être franc monsieur chintron carton
rouge pour l'instant donc voilà bon vous
personnellement non euh vous avez fait
quelques efforts je suis d'accord mais
après voilà on a à la politique de
François Hollande qui amène quand même à
une austérité très importante là-dessus
et il va vraiment falloir remettre une
priorité vraiment nationale sur le
département avec des grands enjeux des
grandes ambitions et au moins revenir à
une politique de bon sens alors ich je
vais vous donner la parole peut-être on
va commencer par la par la dette puisque
et Monsieur Lotto et Monsieur àoin
pardon et Monsieur Lotto en parlait
notamment de de des échos de lundi qui
effectivement érigeit la sonéloire en
maître de gestion pour avoir réduit sa
dette je crois que c'est 520 € par
habitant c'est ça maintenant exactement
ou un peu plus 500 554 € exactement euh
la sonnéloire est sauvée ça veut dire
mais ça veut dire que contrairement à
ceelle a été au bord du gouffre quand
même contrairement à ce qu'il vient
d'être dit la sonnéloire a une dette
inférieure à la moyenne des départements
de France elle a une dette bien
inférieure aux trois autres départements
bourguignon je vais le rappeler
puisqueeffectivement nous sommes à 554 €
par habitant la Côte d'Or est à 600 €
c'est dire à peu près 10 % de plus
Lyonne est à 656 € c'estàd presque à 20
% de plus et la Nièvre est à 852 €
c'est-à-dire presque à 50 % de plus donc
il faut savoir de quoi on parle voilà
donc la dette quand on investit il est
normal de s'en Detter tous les
départements ont une dette ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'elle soit soutenable nous avons
fait en sorte de la diminuer pour que
justement elle soit soutenable et qui
nous permett de continuer à maintenir
nos investissements à une hauteur de 85
millions d'euros moi je suis très étonné
à la fois dans la bouche de Monsieur
acarier et de Monsieur allouin o on nous
parle que de politique nationale et de
François Hollande écoutez François
Hollande il est pas à la tête du
département de sonetloire donc nous nous
je vous n'avez aucun projet aucune
proposition pour pour le département
d'ailleurs ni aujourd'hui ni même dans
l'ensemble des documents que vous avez
vous avez envoyé le Front national
d'ailleurs c'est carrément Marine Le Pen
qui est sur les les professions de foi
euh nous vous avez bien vu que c'était
pas François Hollande qui était sur
notre profession de FO nous nous avons
programme pour les son et notre s fr
national et sans se cacher
VO vous avez mais écoutez dans la
majorité départementale il y a une
minorité d'élus qui sont encartés
socialistes donc on ne met pas
l'étiquette socialiste à quelqu'un qui n
l''est pas pas plus que communiste ou et
j'ai vu d'ailleurs que l'UMP ne met pas
non plus ni le logo UMP ni udi parce que
ils ne sont pas tous à l'UMP ils sont
pas tous à l'UDI vous a priori ils sont
tous au Front national mais on ne sait
pas où ils sont parce que
géographiquement nousavons on a beaucoup
de mal à pouvoir avoir des candidats en
face j'ai fait un débat radiophonique le
candidat de Louan s'est fait remplacer
par le candidat de Rous surs qui est
venu nous parler du canton de Louan ce
qui est quand même totalement abant et
été annulé donc vous étiz à cuiser et
vous étiez pour l'émission de cuiserie
alors vous êtes candidat à Pierre de
sens nous nos candidats sont des grands
actifs donc oui pour le débat de louant
la personne n' pas pu se déplacer parce
que il est transporteurs routiers donc
toute la journée enfin toute la semaine
il est sur les routes ent en train de
gagner sa son salaire difficilement pour
essayer de joindre les de Boutes on peut
faire débat sur le front national sur la
dette quand même monsieur monsieur vous
vous réclamez un audit financier si vous
êtes élu vous en fa pour alors déjà déjà
plusieurs choses effectivement il y a
une lecture de de l'endettement en
sonellloir alors qu'on nattende pas
autre chose que le président sortant
soit satisfait à 100 % de son bilan
c'est normal il est dans son jeu de rôle
mais il a j'oublie quand même de dire
qu'ils sont aux affaires depuis 2004
c'est-à-dire depuis 11 ans donc pendant
toute la première moitié de ces 11 ans
ils ont creusé la dette ils ont failli
mettre ce département au bord du gouffre
et après ils ont passé le reste du temps
à essayer de corriger la tendance
c'est-à-dire on a perdu 11 ans on a
perdu 11 ans sur cet endettement alors
évidemment on peut prendre des
références la corise évidemment c'est le
plus mauvais élève de de France alors
c'est vrai la sonéoire est mieux placée
que la corè ceci dit quand on reprend
des chiffres juste des audits aussi fait
par BFM Business 6 il vienent de
paraître 63e place pour les dépenses
d'investissement la sonéoire 74e place
pour les dépenses en faveur des collèges
65e place en faveur des dépenses de voir
55 positions 55 positions pour la dette
c'est-à-dire 10 fois 10 fois plus
supérieur aux bons élèves alors quand on
parle aussi de l'augmentation des impôts
sur 11 ans c'est 32,5 c'est pas anoda et
est-ce que moi je me pose la question
vous avez fait 16 et sur les TR
dernières années de votre mandature est
est-ce que l'habitant de
sonéloire est-ce qu'il est plus heureux
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 11 ans est-ce que
celui qui a perdu son boulot parce que
le département s'est désengagé dans le
même sens que l'État c'est-à-dire on est
en train d'étrangler les collectivités
locales et suite à ça cette personne a
perdu son travail est-ce qu' lui il est
satisfait de ce bilan moi je suis pas
d'accord pour ça vous voulezire vous
voulez refaire ce que faisait la
présidence de René beumon est-ce que
c'est votre modèle vous dit il y a 11
ans on était peut-être plus heureux
est-ce que étaient plus heureux ils
allent aux États-Unis au Japon et en
Chine non alors monsur monsieur chintron
ne parle que du passé moi je vous parle
d'avenir nous si on VI aus affaires
notre position elle est très claire même
si c'est pas une compétence obligatoire
on va se mobiliser sur l'emploi et il y
a des leviers pour se mobiliser sur
l'emploi vous allez perdre la cause de
complétence générale est-ce que vous
allez pouvoir agir concrètement sur
l'emploi vous savez les compétences avec
les l'état actuel l'état c'està-dire nos
gouvernement ça change tous les jours c
semain en semain c'estàdire les
électeurs vont aller se prononcer sur
des élections départementales en ne
connaissant pas totalement les les
compétences de plus
plus je sais ça gne parce que c'est vrai
je rejoins je rejoins vos étiquettes
vous les avez
caché on voit
plus pas du tout on s'ffiche
clair pas afficher on s'affiche
clairement comme l'Union de la Droite du
centre et de la société civile
parective effectivement l'ensemble des
candidats malgré tout affiche pour ceux
qui sont encartés leurs étiquettes mais
franchement le citoyen c'est pas son
problème pour l'instant ce qu'il veut
lui c'est qu'on réponde à son problème
d'emploi de confort de vie et quand vous
avez l'État et cette assemblée
départementale majoritaire socialiste
qui va dans dans le même sens
c'est-à-dire qui étrangle les
collectivités et qui oublie complètement
l'emploi je pense qu'il y a un
véritablement changement à faire euh une
des dépenses on va dire qui est un peu
contesté de par et d'autrre
c'est la dépense faite pour la marque
sonéloir c'était utile vous avez les
retours est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas
est-ce que ça été d'ailleurs de beaucoup
de régions beaucoup de départements on
laner ses marques de territoire parce
qu'elles permettent de mieux identifier
de mieux valoriser ce qui est fait sur
le territoire saz son et Loir la
Bourgogne ça ça parle beaucoup tout le
monde sait à peu près placer la
Bourgogne sur une sur une carte de
France ça parle dans l'Europe entière ça
parle dans le monde entier Sonel Loir
malheureusement ça ne parlait pas à
beaucoup de personnes donc il faut il
faut corriger cela et donc nous avons le
premier le premier but a été déjà de
fédérer les énergie interne à la
sonelloire cette marque finalement c'est
le département qui l'a lancé mais
aujourd'hui c'est un comité de marque
qui la gère le département fait partie
des 150 ambassadeurs et vous avez les
trois chambres consulaires la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie la Chambre des
Métiers la Chambre d'Agriculture vous
avez des grandes entreprises d'ailleurs
le comité de marque est présidé par un
patron d'entreprise euh vous avez des
clubs sportifs comme les lanchalon qui
sont dedans les grands sites culturels
sont ici la poste de sonnéir qui a
d'ailleurs dévopé ou moi j'ai deux
questions à quoi ça sert déjà une marque
concrètement et est-ce que le nom
franchement sonnéir créative Lab la
Bourgogne ça permet d'avoir une bannière
commune et maintenant tous ces gens-là
communiquent ensemble moi je suis très
heureux que les trois chambres
consulaires aujourd'hui communiquent
ensemble sous cette bannière euh il y a
eu le
salon le salon international du tourisme
et bien tout le monde était sous la
bannière de la marque soneloir créative
la Bourgogne et c'est ça qui est
important c'est de se fédérer derrière
une marque soneloir seul ça ne suffit
pas comme
marque mais c'est pas vrai et il faut
mais il faut lui laisser du temps pour
s'installer vous parle sur le terrain de
votre logo personne conna ça fait d'
mais il faut du temps elle vient être
lancé euh il faut du temps pour qu'elle
s'installe effectivement que il y ait
une reconnaissance aujourd'hui la Poste
l'utilise euh par exemple le Crédit
Agricole s associé également à cette
marque sonelloir La Poste a lancé
d'ailleurs une série de timbres
spécifique euh sur les les photos les
plus emblématiques de sonelir sur les
sites les plus emblématiques donc tout
ça produit ses effets mais déjà en
interne avant même de les produire en
externe et ça a rendu fier les
sonnetloiriens de se retrouver au
donc vous en êtes satisfait visibleement
nous en sommes très satisfaits il faut
vous auriez fait la même chose écoutez
le président sortant vous verrez tout au
long des débat est fier de tout et il a
un bilan il défendra complètement non
franchement dans la situation financière
dans laquelle on est je pense qu'il est
indécent de dépenser 300000 € sans avoir
des retombées économiques il faut je
pense avoir comme pour tout une vraie
lisibilité et se poser la question de
temps en temps si l'euro dépensé est
bien dépensé moi j'aime entendre parler
de la sonéoire pour Sault viticulture
pour son agriculture pour son art de
vivre ça j'aime cette soneloire et
effectivementous av fa affich monsieur
le Président sortant j'ai la délicatesse
de ne pas vous interrompe vous pouvez en
faire autant donc tout simplement j'aime
quand on parle de cette sonire
la sonire on en a parlé l'année dernière
il y a pas eu besoin de dépenser 300000
€ hein votre collègue du conseil général
Thomas Tou a réussi à faire parler dans
la France anentière de la son loi moi
j'aime pas ça je préfère plutôt que de
la politique spectacle je préfère
effectivement qu'on parle de notre
agriculture de ce que l'on sait faire
des entreprises et là on peut la vendre
effectivement cette son lois mais en
étant beaucoup plus modéré sur les
dépenses sans retomberé économique
François loto vous vous l'avez collé à
l'arrière de votre voiture la la marque
créative la Bourgogne sonnéloire
vraiment pour moi c'est c'est pas ma
tasse de TV he ce truccl mais
bon bon pourquoi pas mais je trouve que
c'est plutôt
amusant quand on voit la gauche essayer
de de de de singer la manière de faire
de de la droite sur ce genre de truc
pourquoi vous dites ça l'idée de la
marque enfin bon c'est ça a quelque
chose peut-être tu dis ça fait d'air
mais en même temps ça a quelque chose
d'un peu gênant de de de donner
une une image privatisée du département
enfin de la chose publique ça ça en
terme d'image je suis pas persuadé que
ce soit que ce soit franchement une
bonne idée mais l'avenir nous le dira
donc les 300000 € vous les auriez pas
mis là-dessus non je les aurait pas mis
là-dessus c'est pas en même temps la mre
à Bo mais V6 millions d'euros je crois
qu' c'est pas c'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga des politiques du département je
rappellerai d'ailleurs qu'on a divisé
par deux le budget communication en 10
an donc les dépenses superféatoires
monsieur Akari c'était Plô le temps où
vous étiez aux affaires je crois que ça
vaut pas le coup de se battre là-dessus
franchement il y a des choses plus
importante alors bah la première le
premier des postes en tout cas
budgetaire c'est toujours l'action
sociale confirme euh quelle marge vous
avez encore aujourd'hui avec les baisses
de dotation de l'État est-ce que vous
avez encore une marge pour pour
travailler et pour faire efficacement
votre métier j'allais dire presque
d'assistant sociale mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous ai dit que ces 5
dernières années nous avons
effectivement contenu nos dépenses
contenu d'ailleurs nos dépenses de de
fonctionnement on les a même diminué ce
qui n'était pas très comp compliqué je
rappellerai quand même ne serait-ce que
le budget du cabinet du président a été
divisé par 5 en 10 ans bon j'ai parlé du
budget communication nous avons contenu
et dépenses de personnel également
aucune création de poste ces ces
dernières années et nous faisons en
sorte de maintenir notre investissement
à 85 millions d'euros donc nous
continuons effectivement à assumer le
rôle de protecteur que qu'a un
département monsieur aloin disait les
gens sont dans la détresse mais nous le
savons et tous les jours nous agissons
nos personnels sociaux agissent à leur
côté pour que ce soit sur le question de
logement que ce soit sur les questions
de dépendance sur les questions de de
handicap et c'est vrai que le
département c'est la collectivité des
solidarités des solidarités humaines et
des solidarités intergénérationnelles et
des solidarités aussi territoriales donc
nous faisons en sorte et nous avons fait
en sorte justement en diminuant notre
dette de nous garder effectivement ces
possibilités
d'intervention humaine auprès de nos
concitoyens
oui c'est pour ça ça me fait doucement
rire que vous aidez nos aînés et n enfin
les handicapés ça je vaux encore bien le
croire mais encore faut-il revaloriser
encore la pas ou euh et la pas c'est
fixé au niveau national rien mais quand
nous entendons des personnes de 83 ans
ne pas toucher leur retraite depuis le
17 février ça oui mais je suis bien
d'accord mais quand j'entends encore vos
collègues so de la majorité
départemental parce qu'il faut cacher le
mot socialiste dire si vous êtes dans le
besoin allez voir une assistante sociale
c'est parce qu'elle demande ces
personnes comprenez bien que qu'ell
nattendent qu'une chose c'est qu'elles
ont travaillé toute leur vie elles ont
don elles ont donné leur denier auprès
des impôts ou autres donc il est quand
même tout à fait normal qu'elles
touchent leur retraite elles n'ont pas
besoin d'aller voir une assistante
sociale mais le département on ve faire
du social pour des personnes qui sont en
grande difficulté certes mais après il
va falloir aussi pour ainsi dire avoir
beaucoup plus de contrôle sur l'action
sociale sur l'attribution du du RSA la
dissimulation de revenus donc vous êtes
très content aussi de nous afficher
comme quoi 84 dossiers ont été donc
suivi et vous avez récupéré 600000 € si
nous regardons bien nous faisons un
petit peu les divisions ça fait quand
même une fraude de 700000 7000 € par
dossier euh ramener par les indus les
indus sont compris dedans oui mais bon
euh on ne poursuit pas pour un ind de
100 € on poursuit uniquement quand c'est
une fraude avéré
bien éid justement il faut donner les
moyens on sait très bien on le sait très
bien dans notre entourage ou autre nous
avons des témoignages de personnes qui
fraudent au RSA ou quoi que ce soit si
vous avez des témoignages de il faut les
dénoncer monsieur vot rôle nous les
dénonçons monsieur monsieur chintron
nous les dénonçons parce que nous nous
avons les personnes dans notre entourage
proche ou autre donc nous avons la
dissimulation de reven c'est la CA qui
fait les contrôles he c'est pas tout à
fait mais il faut que le conseil aussi
général qui donne
euh voilà c'est vous qui attribuez quand
même le RSA ça représente beaucoup ça la
prode on peut dire non c'est moins d' 1
% c'est c'est très minime je voudrais
donner juste un chiffre je voudrais
donner juste un chiffre en soneloir on
dépense pour le RSA 87 € par habitant la
moyenne nationale est à 127 €. pourquoi
parce que il y a moins de bénéficiires
du RSA en moyenne en sonéloire que dans
le reste du département pourquoi parce
que contrairement à ce que Monsieur
Akari a dit le taux de chômage tout le
monde peut le reprendre c'est un chiffre
quand même qui est national le taux de
chômage en son et noir est inférieur à
la moyenne
nationale
département pour trouver du boulot
ailleurs ils vont sur la Côte d'Or ils
vont sur lon ils V pas la fraude
puisquil y a beaucoup moins de
bénéficiire du
RS ce que dit la droite justement que
que Andr and vous la lutte contre la
frude r ça c'est l'une des premières
lignes de votre programme est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec Monsieur
allouin donc qui a beaucoup de fraude ou
quand monsieur chanton vous dit ça
représente 1 % est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
un levier est-ce qu'on peut récupérer de
l'argent si si on combat la fr plus
fortement sonir contre contre ceux qui
qui trichent au RSA je pense qu'il faut
déjà sur ce dossier être calme et
objectif monsieur chintron parle
effectivement que la fraude quasiment
n'existe pas c'est fait bon il faut pas
non plus il faut pas non plus voilà tout
tout renier comme ça c'est un phénomène
qui existe et à l'heure où effectivement
les l'État est en train d'étrangler les
collectivités mais Mme le département
c'est un fait et là où je peux le
rejoindre c'est qu'il faut effectivement
remettre à plat l'ensemble des
politiques y compris les politiques du
département afin de retrouver des marges
de manœuvre nous effectivement on on
souhaite le faire ça fait partie d'une
priorité dans le social effectivement on
veut remettre à PL certaines choses et
effectivement au moment de l'instruction
du dossier je pense qu'il y a un
contrôle appui à faire pourquoi parce
que c'est certains département moi je ve
pas entrer dans une bataille de chiffres
mais certains départements sont allés
sur ce terrainl ils ont l'ex expérience
tant qu'à faire il faut prendre les
bonnes expériences qui marchent ailleurs
et quand certains départements ont
constaté lorsqu'ils ont fait et je Renis
pas le travail formidable de des des
salariés du conseil général qui
effectivement font ce qu'ils peuvent
mais il faut les aider faut les appuyer
il faut recréer une cellule en plus de
façon à les aider elle ferait quoi cette
cellule à justement à contrôler un peu
plus les dossiers de façon à retrouver
certaines marche de manœuvre et enlever
cet argent qui est destiné à des gens
qui essayent de tricher et le redonner à
des gens qui en ont réellement besoin
c'est ça en fait c'est un un principe de
gestion de bon père de famille et on
sait que là où ça s'est fait on a des
résultats quand même assez probant et
quand on parle d'e économie et quand
certains départements disent bah voilà
on a commencé à s'y intéresser on arrive
à économiser 400000 € non on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin et effectivement il y
a des gens qui ont réellement qui sont
vraiment dans le besoin hein quand on
parle du chômage moi je suis désolé
monsieur chron vous parlez de la
Bourgogne parlez de la Bourgogne janvier
les dernier chiffre c'est la sonelloire
la plus mal placée c'est la seule qui
augmente son
chômage c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça
que
nous bien sûr mais je vous donne quand
même ces chiffres là c'est vrai que en
sonelloir tout va bien tout va bien
vraiment les gens de sonelir sont
heureux de ce bilan c'est extraordinaire
je vois tous les matins ceux qui vont
chercher du boulot ils sont parfaitement
heureux de de de cette gestion c'est
évident et d'ailleurs dans quelques
jours on en aura le sujet et le bilan
sur notre site internet on voit des gens
heureux et malheureux
je vous rassure il y a un petit peu des
deux François lotau alors on va un petit
peu passer en revue un peu les thèmes du
département parce qu'on a on a il faut
qu'on avance il est déjà 11h30 il y a un
sujet qui vous divise avec j'allais dire
encore vos amis socialistes c'est le
parc le sintur parc du Rousset si si
d'aventure vous étiez tous élu les les
candidats Europe Écologie ver vous
arrêteré ce projet oui certainement je
voudrais tout de même dire un mot sur le
côté un peu désolant du débat auquel on
vient d'ASS parce que bon combattre la
la fraude d'une manière générale la
fraude sociale en particulier d'accord
évidemment mais l'essentiel n'est
évidemment pas
là j'ai pas les chiffres pour la soné
Loire mais au niveau national c'est plus
de 60 % des gens qui devraient
bénéficier du du RSA activité qui n'en
bénéficie pas voilà une chose qu'il faut
développer d'ailleurs à travers les
maisons du département enfin ce genre de
chose faciliter l'accès
euh aux gens qui vraiment ont besoin de
quelque
chose
doiv être absolument désolé de de nous
voir ne parler que de fraude et de ce
genre de chos alors que sont dans une
grande difficulté ces gensl l'immense
majorité de ces gens ne sont pas des
frurs éid un meilleur contrôle avec une
meilleure attribution donc je CIS que
les chiffr sont pas tout à fait
comparable mais bon Center Park oui et
surtout l'argent public de la région et
du conseil général puisqueon on rappelle
que les deux collectivités ont décidé
d'investir dans le projet et d'acquérir
voilà ce qu'on appelle la la bule
l'espace
multiactivité est-ce qu'il faut mettre
de l'argent public dans Center Park
est-ce qu'il faut construire un Center
par 0 millions d'euros 15 million
d'euros pour les collectivit d'EUR en ce
qui concerne les les les les subventions
donc 7 7 7 pour social sont des actions
oui je c pour faire la différence avec
ce qui ensuite serait les sommes
emprunté via la société d'économie mixte
bon et là c'est
66 il faut mettre de l'argent public sur
des projets touristiques structurants et
qui en même temps sont susceptibles
d'être créateurs d'emploi le projet du
Conseil Général conseil départemental à
l'avenir c'est bien de de de de de
favoriser ce genre de chose mais là
franchement mettre tous SZ ufs ou une
bonne partie parce que c'est tout de
même des sommes très importantes sur un
point alors que il est il serait
souhaitable de d'avoir une répartition
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus homogène sur
le sur les différents territoires du
département c'est déjà un souci ensuite
ne pas s'être posé la question de
demander aux citoyens comment on peut
faire euh comment est-ce qu'on va faire
ce développement structurant touristique
pardon il y a un débat public qui va
être organisé sur le sur le paroui
heureusement et ça c'est une c'est une
très bonne chose mais il aurait fallu
aussi et pour éviter que ce genre de
dysfonctionnement surviennent à l'avenir
de nouvelles fois il aurait fallu partir
des projets de de proposé par la
population plutôt que d'arriver avec une
solution clé en main c'est c'est une
solution de
facilité les élus ont ont trop
facilement tendance à à aller dans ce
sens ça veut dire qu'une entreprise qui
veut s'implanter vous vous n'essayez pas
de de effectivement de l'aider à
s'implanter mais il s'agit pas de
l'implantation d'une entreprise d'abord
il s'agit un site touristique d'un grand
groupe on parle 300 emplois on parle de
300 emplois là aussi il faut que les
choses soient étudiées correctement pour
le moment euh
je rappelle que la Cour des comptes par
exemple en 2012 avait avait épinglé un
autre Center Park dans dans une autre
région en disant que les les les les
études sur les emplois n'étaient faites
que par l'employeur lui-même donc voilà
il
faut mais sur le plan environnemental de
toute manière il y a aussi cet aspect là
comment est-ce qu'on peut aller mettre
des sommes aussi importantes dans un
dans un dans un unique projet l' où à la
fin de cette année on doit recevoir à
Paris la conférence sur le climat et là
on
va poser une bulle tropicale chauffée à
28°gr toute l'année au milieu du
charelet d'abord si le charelet est
attractif il a pas besoin
qu'on qu' qu'on ait besoin de s'imaginer
qu'on va dans les tropiques pour aller
dans le charrolet
bon c'est c'est c'est choquant c'est
très dispendieux en énergie en eau tous
les problèmes ne sont pas réglés
l'enquête d'utilité publique n'est pas
faite sur ce sujet
euh non franchement Center Park c'est
une très mauvaise idée aussi bien celui
du Rousset que celui du Jura allez ben
ça amène une réponse bien sûr écoutez
euh nous nous avons besoin de faire de
la saudelloire une destination
touristique majeure le Ster Park c'est
630000 nuités qui sont attendus pour un
par an pour un taux de remplissage de 80
% donc on peut même faire mieux mais
mettons à 80 % 630000 nuités ça augmente
de 50 % le nombre de nuités en sonn et
Loire actuel tout hébergement confondu
pourquoi parce qu'un Center Park 400
cottèges qui fonctionneent 12 mois sur
12 euh un git que nous aidons par
ailleurs je rappelle que euh nous
donnons 600000 € de subventions aux
hébergements euh tous les ans euh à ceux
qui se développent notamment en ce
moment sur le neourisme sur les
hébergements insolites et cetera et là
en subvention pas tis que pour ça à fond
perdu tandis que pour le cter Park je le
rappelle c'est un investissement nous
nous investissons dans une société
publique d'économie mixte qui
effectivement va porter une partie de
l'investissement 15 millions sur 170
millions d'investissement au total nous
déclenchons 170 millions
d'investissement et nous allons et le
but est aussi de récupérer notre mise
comme les autres actionnaires comme les
autres investisseurs dans le modèle cter
Park alors moi j'entends bien que je
comprends euh aussi la vision écologique
sur sur la question de la bulle des
28°gr mais vous savez euh discuter avec
les gens autour de vous moi ce qui est
beaucoup plus consommateur d'énergie
c'est tous ces gens qui prennent l'avion
pour aller effectivement durant l'hiver
une semaine euh en Tunisie au Maroc dans
les Maldives ou autres et ces gens-là
s'il n'y a si on peut leur offrir une
offre en sonéloire en France
c'est-à-dire et de permettre déjà parce
que la consommation d'un avion euh c'est
plus que les 28 degr de de la bulle et
oui je suis désolé non c'est pas
fallacieux et créer les emplois ici en
soneloir je pense que c'est mieux que de
laisser créer ailleurs parce que tout le
monde demande des cterp tout le monde
demande des cterp nous sommes B nous
nous sommes battus euh pour pour pour
l'avoir ce sont 300 emplois directs pour
une partie alors 250 équivalent en plein
on est d'accord 250 équivalent en plein
et l'INC a sorti une é sur ce qui s'est
réalisé en laorine et en Lorine c'est 90
emplois extérieurs en plus parce que il
y a aussi l'approvisionnement c'est 5
million d'euros d'approvisionnement
local hein parce que bien évidemment ces
gens ils consomment hein donc il faut
rappeler cela donc au total c'est
presque 400 emplois voilà est-ce qu'on
peut se passer de cela 250 emplois et
estimé entre direct et entre 150 et 200
en indir pour la construction du Center
par non mais et puis pour la provision C
par c'est 90 emplois à l'année dans les
fournisseurs national on est toujours
très attentif aux effets d'annonce c'est
quand même un groupe qui a quand même
accusé une perte de 50 millions d'euros
cette fin d'année pas sur les Center
Park sur le reste des résidences mais
comme tous les groupes touristiquese
beaucoup de ches comme tous les groupes
d'hébergementi% je trouve que bon 15
millions donc du conseil général 66 par
la
SEM 7 et dem du conseil général région
qui donne l' non mais tout à fait mais
je suis quand même très méfiant à ce
niveau-là ça peut très bien marcher
sur qu'est-ce qui nous garantit la
périnité du projet dans l'avenir ah mais
vous savez il faut il y a toujours c'est
un modèle qui existe depuis 20 ans donc
on espère quand même sur certain Center
par une baisse des fréquentation au fur
à mesure des ann C par est dans la
branche du groupe Pierre et Vacances
l'élément le plus le plus rentable et
qui continue à être rentable malgré la
crise je rappelle que tous les groupes
d'hébergement touristiques ont perdu 10
% donc ils sont tous en perte sèche sauf
sur Pier et vacan sur les centter Park
c'est un modèle qui se développe
aujourd'hui donc nous paronss
effectivement alors vous savez bon il y
a toujours un risque hein mais quand
vous investissez pour quand vous
investissez pour l'implantation d'une
entreprise il y a toujours un risque
mais le risque quand vous il y a quand
même 170 millions de construction doncz
ils sont les 15 millions que nous
mettons ils sont quand même garantis par
les 170 millions de construction qui
seront quand même là c'est pas du vous
allez la revendre ça marche plus aè ça
c'est ça peut
s'exit on ne se place pas dans cette
perspective là ce
trie partout ailleurs ça fonctionne je
vois pas pourquoi il fonction pas chez
nous et la droite l'pposition est plutôt
favorable au projet mais n'importe
comment là-dessus il n'y a aucune
ambigué de notre positionnement parce
que dès le début effectivement on a
suivi sur ce dossier je vous rappellerai
d'ailleurs le premier site qui étaé
visité c'était plutôt du secteur de
saint-bonjou qui est un de nos collègues
donc évidemment il y a pourquoi parce
que ça va le sens de l'attractivité de
l'emploi c'est comme ça que j'aime qu'on
parle de la sonéloire mais attention il
faut pas se tromper non plus c'est pas
euh la collectivité conseil général de
de de son noir fait ce que n'importe
quelle collectivité ferait dans une
telle situation à de plus petite
position nous sur le le canton de
parmonial c'est la même chose quand une
entreprise vient on on va l'accueillir
on va faire en sorte que si par pas de
en particulier non vousê d'accord mais
en tout cas on fera tous la même chose
acteur économique responsable quand on a
pardon acteur public responsable quand
on a une proposition d'une entreprise
parce qu'il faut pas inverser les rôles
he c'est une entreprise privée qui vient
s'installer en son et Loir qui en tout
cas annonce son projet donc c'est quand
même c'est pas le projet du Conseil
général c'est le projet d'un
entrepreneur d'une entreprise qui veut
s'installer tout simplement parce que
elle y trouve les conditions et c'est à
nous effectivement élus de créer les
conditions pour que cette entreprise
puisse s'installer et que le dossier
aboutisse parce que derrière c'est notre
combat c'est l'emploi et on est dans une
situation telle que tout ce que l'on
peut faire pour attirer les entreprises
ou les nouveaux habitants et bien
effectivement il faut y mettre les
bouché doubles donc sur cette position
là nous nous n'avons aucune ambigué bien
sûr rester attentif sur le denier public
savoir aussi bien bien étudier les
retombées et faire en sorte que le
contrat soit plutôt bien négocié alors
je vais poursuivre ce sujet l'argent
public et comment accompagner des
projets privé vous parlez beaucoup de
évidemment des des maisons de retraite
c'est une question qui se pose dans
sonloir c'est un département
vieillissant est-ce que l'opposition
souhaite donner plus un coup de pouce à
des maisons de retraite privées à des
projets privés on voit que c'est pas
trop ce que veut faire la majorité
est-ce que vous c'est c'est pas un tabou
le privé non c'est alors c'est pas un
tabou mais attention là aussi euh tout
d'abord le 3e et le 4e âge euh il faut
pas on peut pas amer que sur un seul
projet il y a plusieurs choses à faire
en effet il faut inciter aussi notamment
dans les villages ruraux à ce que les
communes et ça c'est par le bien aussi
du conseil général en appui financier
les communes aent des projets tout
simplement de petites infrastructure
quand une personne âgée ne peut plus euh
habiter parce qu'elle habite une
ancienne ferme et bien il faut tout
simplement pour que le décalage soit
moins important lui permettre aussi de
rester dans sa village c'est-à-dire en
poussant effectivement financièrement
des installations adaptées aux personnes
et aux seniors après effectivement on a
les les maisons de retraite alors il y a
de deux possibilités vous faites un un
financement à 100 % par le conseil
général d'un établissement
ou alors
vous choisissez aussi la position qui
est plutôt la nôtre c'est-à-dire de
mettre de l'argent certes mais moins de
façon à avoir plusieurs projets en sonn
et Loire puisque on sait
qu'effectivement avec la courbe des âges
et en plus ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle l'espérance de vie étant de
plus en plus importante il faudra
effectivement faire beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup plus fort en signe de cette
politiques des seiors donc faut du privé
des maisons de retraite privé c'est pas
vous quand vous lancez un projet quand
vous mettez quand vous le financez pas à
100 % vous mettez effectivement un peu
de privé mais aussi d'autres partenaires
publics vous n'êtes pas obligé de mettre
et de pour le coup qu'est-ce que vous
allez avoir en l'espace de 11 ans une
seule maison de retraite si vous la
financez seulement avec une collectivité
donc l'intérêt maintenant avec la
croissance de l'âge il faudra bien
effectivement miser un peu plus faire
des efforts supplémentaires mais ça veut
dire aussi que le département doit
trouver des marges financières de façon
à remettre un peu d'argent en en
direction de la Politique de zoau aîné
un petit tour de temp sur cette question
Sébastien loin oui bon qu'on veuille
encore créer des des maisons médicales
pour no aînés c'est très bien mais il ne
faut quand même pas oublier non plus les
aînés qui sont encore très vaillants que
ça soit l'âge de 80 90 ans et qui
souhaitent encore rester dans leur
maison il va falloir aussi les
accompagner par le B de domotique de
téléassistance ou quoi que ce soit pas
la peine non plus de construire une
unité spécifique dans chaque village
s'ils ont quand même travaillé tout le
adapté c'est des logements adaptés s'ils
ont travaillé toute leur vie pour avoir
un bien locatif autant les laisser chez
eux après voilà que qui rest chez eux
c'est c'est aussi des aides pour des
travaux sur des bâtiments qui leur
appartiennent donc après il va falloir
aussi euh apporter un peu plus au niveau
des épades ou autres euh un moyen humain
car on on se rend compte que que ça soit
un petit peu partout sur la sonéloire
dans les épades il manque aussi du
personnel pour pouvoir aider au maximum
nos aînés qui sont convalescents dans
dans ces unités et et contrairement à
aujourd'hui il y a ce manque aussi de
personnel donc il va bien falloir aussi
combl et c'est compatible avec les
économies que vous voulez faire comme
vous nous le disiez au début de de cette
émission ah mais tout à fait c'est
compatible on peut il y a encore
beaucoup d'économie à faire sur le
département hein donc il y a encore
certaines niches encore à les creuser
donc avec toutes ces niches on peut
toujours les les impacter pour la
vieillesse pour l'handicap pour la
petite enfance donc il y a encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et
donnons-nous vraiment les moyens nous
voyons l'âge de nos aînés reculés de
d'année en année donc il faut vraiment
les accompagner jusqu'au bout Rémy
chintteron vous dans votre projet il y a
des constructions de structures qui ne
seraient pas des tout à fait des maisons
de retraite alors tout d'abord je vais
dire je suis assez effaré par la manque
le manque de connaissance de de mes
adversaires sur ce sur ce sujetl je vis
quand même rappeler quelques principes
premièrement les places d'pad c'est pas
uniquement une question financière
puisqu'il faut qu'ell soit
autorisée par l'État hein par l'agence
régionale de santé et donc il n'y a
aucune place qui ne nous est échappé
hein je veux dire que d'ailleurs les
dernières qui ont été accordées à la
Bourgogne 58 pour toute la Bourgogne ont
été récupéré entièrement pour la soné
Loire pas parce que nous avons tapé du
point sur la table un petit peu quand
même mais simplement parce qu'il y a du
rattrapage à réalisé donc nous prenons
toutes les places deuxièmement je
voudrais rappeler la situation qui a été
celle d'il y a 10 ans quand les amis de
Monsieur Akari étaient aux affaires et
qui d'ailleurs se propose de revenir à
ce modèle là c'est-à-dire le tout privé
pas du tout en deux décennies
avant 2004 aucune création de mais de
retraite publique dans ce département
nous avons créé 1000 places en 11 ans
1000 places nous sommes passés de 6700
places à 7700 places aujourd'hui le
département accorde 30000 € c'estàd 30 %
par place créé aujourd'hui pour faire
baisser les prix justement du public je
voudrais rappeler les tarifs et
d'ailleurs ça a été ils ont été publiés
par l'UFC Que Choisir la moyenne
département des épades publques le tarif
d'ébargement moyen est à 1650 € en privé
il est à 2607 € quand on connaît le
niveau de retraite des sonnetloiriennes
et des sonnetloiriens qui pour 80 % ont
des retraites inférieures à 1500 € vous
comprenez bien que le privé c'est pour
une toute petite minorité donc nous
avons rééquilibré les choses maintenant
ce que nous proposons s'agissant du
personnel les ratios non mais très
rapidement mais les ratios de personnel
sont supérieurs en son qui ne sont en
moyenne nationale nous avons
0,62 personnels par place despad 0,62
personnels par place d'pad c'est-à-dire
il y a 62 personnels dans un épad 200
places la moyenne nationale est plutôt à
0,57 on est au-dessus on peut
certainement faire mieux mais le
problème c'est que ça fait augmenter les
prix pour les personnes et donc ils ne
peuvent pas forcément assumer les
personnels ils sont aussi payés par
l'État et pas par le Conseil Général
pour les personnels médicaux c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont autorisés nous souhaitons
développer également au-delà des des pad
bien évidemment nous allons continuer à
développer parce qu'il y a des besoins
on a une population vieillissante des
résidences senior publiques parce que
qui sont non médicalisés c'est une il y
a il y a de l'offre privée aujourd'hui
mais une offre privée avec en partie je
suis désolé de le dire mais des
marchands de sommeil hein qui en fait
loue des chambres à 1000 € par mois sans
aucun service sans aucune sécurité pour
nos concitoyens nous nous voulons
développer avec l'opaque sonelloir une
offre publique on a rien contre le privé
mais il faut que les gens aient le choix
ils doivent avoir choix entre le
maintien à domicile et je crois qu'en la
matière et d'ailleurs on dépense 30 % de
plus que la moyenne des autres
départements je l'ai rappelé sur la pas
parce qu'il y a plus de personnes âgées
et parce que je pense que nous avons des
dispositifs qui sont effectivement
meilleurs que en moyenne en moyenne
nationale et donc il faut qu'ils aient
le choix également de la résidence
senior et puis qu'ils ai le choix mais
toujours en public entre le public et le
privé et qu'ils aient le choix entre
Lespes public et les P allez un mot sur
ce sujet François loto et puis on va
passer un peu à la politique oui mais je
vais quand même dire un mot alle non
parce que mais rapidement s'il vous
plaît alors très rapidement euh c'est
simplement le schéma que remémy chintron
donne non la droite c'est pas de tout
privé loin de là et j'ai pas dit ça
d'ailleurs parce que effectivement on a
conscience al tout d'abord monsieur Remy
chintron ne parle que du passé sans
arrêt il revient toujours au passé bon
moi je vous parle d'avenir et
effectivement la situation en sonelloire
a changé et on peut pas faire il faut
effectivement à l'heure où les dotations
sont en chute libre sur les
collectivités il va falloir
effectivement trouver des partenariats
mais aussi d'autres partenariats publics
et les solutions pour les résidences
pour personnes âgées elles ne peuvent
pas seulement venir que du conseil
général elle peut venir aussi en appui
sur d'autres collectivités et quand je
parle en effet de d'aller plus loin sur
les projets notamment avec les communes
et avec les intercommunités on reste
aussi sur du public malgré tout et aussi
une maîtrise parce que j'ai bien
conscience la différence avec R Charton
j'ai travaillé dans le privé donc je
sais comment ça se passe aussi hein donc
effectivement on connaît aussi l'état de
nos retraites on sait on connaît ces
dossiers là et effectivement il faut
avoir une action très forte sur le prix
parce que ça n'est pas supportable et on
a des Besons de retraite beaucoup plus
élevé médicalisé vous vous trompez une
1000 € on est sur une moyenne de
certaines maison de retraite de 2500 €
effectivement quelqu'un qui gagne 600 à
1000 € ça n'est pas possible Françis l
oui ben la dépendance a un cout
évidemment mais c'est un choix de
société
euh
j'ai malgré tout quelques doutes sur la
philanthropie du secteur privé dans ce
domaine c'est pas sa fonction sa
fonction c'est sa fonction c'est de
gagner de l'argent non mais c'est pas ce
que je défends gagner de
l'argent avec des hébergements qui
coûtent 2500 € par mois avec des gens
qui eux touchent 6 ou 800 € il y a un
souci il y a quelque chose qui n'est pas
possible là donc la la la réponse là
elle est publique et la réponse elle est
celle d'un choix de société de partage
de solidarité et ben oui la population
vieillit il a des maladies
qu'on considère aujourd'hui dans le
domaine médico-social la maladie
d'Alzheimer mais ce sont des maladies
qu'il faut traiter qu'il faut prendre en
charge et et et tout ça c'est l'onneur
d'un
sociéleités c'est la solidarité
nationale et et au-delà et c'est un
c'est un choix de société et on peut pas
on peut pas
développer une une approche sérieuse de
ce genre de question uniquement sous
l'angle de de la rentabilité bien sûr
des opérations la rentabilité bien sûr
mais à l'échelle de de la rentabilité
sociale et non pas uniquement financière
sur sur des projets et des partenariats
public privés il nous reste un petit peu
plus de 5 minutes avant midi j'aimerais
bien qu'on aborde quand même l'aspect
politique he de de ces
élections et notamment du contexte un
peu national on a entendu REM chon cette
semaine on a entendu monsieur cambadéis
dire que on assistait à un vrai su suici
politique en direct de la gauche parce
qu'il n'y avait pas d'accord suffisant
en tout cas en nombre sur l'ensemble des
cantons en France est-ce que vous êtes
suicidaire parce que c'est le cas aussi
en sonéois où la gauche apparaît comme
étant assez divisée même si le Parti
socialiste a réussi à peu près son unit
bah écoutez on n'est pas si divisé que
cela d'ailleurs avec François lotau avec
François lotau on se rejoint sur la
plupart des sujets vous avez bien
compris que c'était sur le Center Park
où nous avions des visions différentes
je vois que la droite est divisé aussi
sur sur un certain nombre de de cantons
en sonir bien sûr que c'est mieux quand
on est uni derrière un bilan derrière
derrière un projet mais on peut
comprendre aussi qu'il y ait des
sensibilités qui au premier tour veulent
pouvoir se faire entendre ESS per
essayer de peser sur sur les choix mais
écoutez celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
fait l'union emportent la
responsabilité simplement c'est que je
pense que ce qu'a dit Monsieur
cambadellis c'était un message qu'il
envoyait en direction des partenaires de
la gauche plurielle pour leur dire
écoutez il faudrait qu'on se rassemble
derrière une bannière commune à gauche
parce que effectivement il y a une il y
a il y a une abstention mais on on se
retrouve sur la plupart des projets et
la plupart des
sujets mais y a une bule entre nous mais
vous savez cette bulle on on entame un
grand débat public parce qu'on a
toujours travaillé de cette manière là
en son et Loir hein sur la question de
la RCE on avait fait une votation
citoyenne sur on a fait Sirius 2030 pour
demander au Sonel waren et Sonel waren
ce qu'ils attendaient de leur
département dans les dans les années à
venir donc on communique on la
démocratie participative on a un Open
Data où on met tout ce que fait le
département chaque dépense vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site Open Data de
sonelir c'est le seul département à le
faire en France de cette manière- là on
a d'ailleurs été primé pour donc on est
d'accord sur la la plupart des sujets et
sur cter Park moi j'ai toujours dit que
nous ne passerions pas en force nous
respecterons l'ensemble des procédures
et nous resp on les conclusions du débat
public voilà François loto alors la
démocratie
si non ENF est que est-ce que Europe
Écologie Les ver n'avit pas intérêt
finalement à faire plus d'alliance avec
j'allais dire un grand parti un parti
voilà qui détient le département
actuellement pour entrer au conseil
départemental plutôt que de partir dans
son coin ici pas dans son coin là ou de
s'aliier avec le front de de gauche
ailleurs mais c'est pas dans son coin
nulle part c'est une dynamique avec des
citoyens et des citoyennes
est-ce que partir dans son coin
s'appelle ça s'ouvrir à la société et si
on s'imagine que euh
euh qu'on pourra avoir un effet
quelconque sur l'abstention euh en en se
mettant tous derrière une
bannière de de de majorité
départementale qui aurait besoin d'un
peu plus de de de de clarté de
définition moi je pense que c'est une
erreur mais de là à vouloir me faire
tenir la seringue du suicide d'assister
dréy chintron non pas du tout euh ça n'a
rien à voir je pense que je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ce le le le bilan est
mitigé on est au milieu du gay ben nous
on veut faire avancer les choses et non
pas les faire reculer Sébastien l moin
euh vous il y a aussi toujours la
question qu'on se pose avec le le Front
national du National justement et du
local on voit que beaucoup de vos
candidats sont un peu en retrait est-ce
que vous c'est une élection vous vouz
surfer sur on les voit pas tous vos
candidats bah après je peux vous
garantir qu'ils sont tous sur le terrain
ils sont partout sur la sonéloire certes
on est un peu plus discret que les
socialiste que la droite ou autres nous
ne faisons pas de réunion publique ça
c'est clair pourquoi nous préférons
aller au contact des gens pourquoi pas
de réunion public euh vous allez nous si
enfin Front national si il organise une
réunion publique nous allons avoir une
grande partie de nos militants qui vont
venir aux réunion donc c'est-à-dire
parler à des déjà des personnes
convaincues ce que nous voulons vraiment
aller chercher c'est les
absentionnistes parce que tout cette
person toutes ces personnes qui ne
viennent plus aux urnes c'est pas la
faute du Front national ou quoi que ce
soit c'est la politique nationale qui a
été menée jusqu'à maintenant par la
droite et par la gauche qui fait que les
gens ne veulent plus aller voter ils ne
se sentent plus écoutés ils se sentent
délaissés ils se sent il se sentent
carrément abandonnés je vous parle même
pas de l'agriculture ou là ils se
sentent vraiment assassinés limite
acculer une ruine certaine et une mort
prochaine donc voilà nous nous préférons
le terrain c'est làù nous pouvons
vraiment recueillir les doléances les
peurs les craintes de chacun leur
questions voilà là au moins on est
vraiment au contact si vous avez des
élus c'est exclu pour vous totalement de
travailler ou avec une majorité de
gauche ou avec une majorité de droite ça
après nous le verrons quand si nous
avons déjà des élus du Front National au
sein du conseil départemental après ça
sera une concertation ensemble avec tous
les binômes sur quelle position apporté
par la suite pour le 3è tour mais pour
l'instant on en est pas là on est
toujours pour un premier tour nous
battons le terrain nous essayons de de
faire revenir les gens aux urnes chose
que certaines personnes et certains
partis ont oublié jusqu'à maintenant
donc voilà alors and carry vous disiez
tout à l'heure aussi que l'abstention
c'était c'était c une crainte comment
vous partez dans cette campagne
notamment en sonéois où il y a encore
cette division mais elle est presque
historique avec Monsieur voisin dans le
sud de la sonéloire alors ça concerne de
canton on va dire alors oui voilà faut
faut relativiser aussi he la j'ai réussi
quand même avec l'ensemble des
formations politiques de droite et aussi
de la société civile il faut pas
l'oublier parce que nous on a de
nombreux candidats issus de la société
civile mais l'UMP l'UDI c'estàd donc les
partis effectivement
cita on a laisser terminer de parler
entre eux effectivement on a réussi à
faire une liste unie sur l'ensemble de
la son Loire voilà alors alors
effectivement nous on ne cache pas nos
étiquettes on on se positionne
effectivement clairement à droite on est
sur le terrain on fait des réunions
publiques parce qu'on a pas peur des
gens on va les voir on va les rencontrer
on est sur le terrain et c'est vrai que
notre démarche c'est une démarche de
pédagogie pourquoi parce que quand même
pendant 2 années au moins ce
gouvernement socialiste soutenu par la
majorité départementale même si
évidemment comme par hasard tout a
disparu on ninvite plus de ministres
j'ai même vu hier on a écart de minist
ils sont obligés de les emmener sur un
secteur où il y a pas de candidat
puisque plus personne veut veut les voir
plus personne veut avoir d'attachche
avec ce gouvernement ceci dit ceci dit
nous notre démarche elle est pédagogique
il faut inciter les gens à aller voter
de façon à s'exprimer et c'est vrai
quand vous avez eu un gouvernement qui a
tout le temps expliqué que les
départements allaient disparaître et
puis finalement qu'ils allaient revenir
mais on va pas garder ses compétences on
va rajouter ça change c'est un vrai
sketch ça change tous les 8 allez on
revient dans 5 minutes sur les enjeux
dans le département là il va être midi
nous allons nous interrompre pour
prendre connaissance de l'actualité à la
mijournée le flash vous est présenté par
Arnaud Lefèvre à tout de suite